euh ces deux élèves de CE2 qui ont été
stoppés ce lundi dans une école de Nice
alors qu'ils organisaient une prière
musulmane regardez est-ce que vous êtes
choqué ou pas par ça où est-ce que vous
trouvez que c'est démesuré la réaction
qu'il a eu choqué ou pas choqué
dites-nous dans l'enceinte d'une école
niissoise deux élèves de CE2 ont
organisé une prière musulmane le maire
de Nice Christian estrozi et la rectrice
de l'académie Natacha Chiko ont dénoncer
des atteintes au principe de laïcité
Christian estrozi a demandé à la
directrice de l'école de convoquer les
en des élèves concernés en juin dernier
Christian estrzi avait déjà alerté la
première ministre à la suite de faits
similaires qui s'était produit dans
trois écoles noise non ou alors est-ce
que vous êtes choqué par cette prière ou
pas du tout vous trouvez que ça c'est
c'est démesuré ce qui s'est passé vous
êtes choqué oui c'est choquant des
élèves comme ça si jeunes qui qui qui
prient qui incitent à prier sur leur
manteau moi ça m'a choqué je suis pour
la liberté de culte mais là à cet âgel
ça signifie quelque chose qui pour la
société française est inquiétant il faut
pas se le cacher très bonne réaction des
autorités municipales monsieur estr et
du rectorat ils ont déjà reçu les
parents séparément des deux famillees et
puis les élèves ont été avertis donc moi
je trouve que c'est bien voilà mais ça
fait pe excusez-moi mais on oublie une
chose c'est que on parle d'enfants là en
l'occurrence CE2 c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
peut-être 7 ou 8 ans c'est-à-dire que si
on considère qu'un enfant de 8 ans il
faut le traiter comme un adulte de 40
qui aurait choisi le chemin de la
radicalisation qui serait inscrit dans
une une démarche éventuellement
terroriste on passe totalement à côté du
sujet c'est des gamins de 6 ou 7 ans qui
probablement savent même pas de quoi il
s'agit qui sont à moitié dans un jeu à
moitié dans un une influence à moitié
dans la reproduction de choses qu'
connaissent pas et le principe vous
savez de l'école parce queon dit a la
limite de 16 ans mais en fait l'idée
qu'on doit instruire les enfants de 16
ans c'est pas juste une obligation qu'on
s'impose c'est que l'obligation morale
qu'on a envers ces enfants même s'ils
font des choses qui sont blâmables et
qui sont pas bien c'est qu'on a
l'obligation de s'occuper d'eux il faut
les reprendre il faut les aider GAM an
ilut pas les traiter comme des
terroristes faut les traiter comme des
enfants à qui on doit expliquer les
choses vous nêtes pas choqué non moi ça
me choque pas déjà ils ont fait une
prière ils ont pas appelé à un attentat
ils sont en CE2 ça veut dire que c'est
c'est ce que je reprends c'est en fait
oui mais d'accord mais on on parle
d'enfants en CE2 ça veut dire que c'est
que du mimétisme à ce stage là ils
reproduis trs
surprant ce sont pas des choses que nous
faisons à la mais qu' vous AZ toujours
des enfants qui vont voler des bonbons
qui vont faire si qui vont faire ça donc
en fait on sait très bien que les
enfants parfois ils ont des
comportements qui n'ont aucun lien avec
la manière dont ils sont éduqués qui
sont parfois dans de la reproduction un
peu de
provocation faut traiter les choses de
telle manière qu'on fasse fil on va pas
mettre dans des camps de
déradicalisation tous les enfants qui
ont un
jource qu' qu'est-ce qu'il a de grave
dans une prière est-ce qu'un enfant ant
radis moi quand j'étais petit j'étais
dans une école publique j'avais des
cours de catéchisme ça choquit qui le
malais faut dire la vérité il est pas
autour de la religion il est autour de
la religion musulmane on est en train de
faire des amalgames entre prière et
enfant radicalisé c'est extrêmement
grave ce qui se passe depuis quand une
prière est un Act illégal Malon
intellectuellement parce qu'on a jamais
dit qu'ils étaient radicalisés de
Monsieur on jamais dit qu'il Fall les
exclure mais là c'est le sujet mais on
est
passéj qu'on
fait é ou pas choqué moi j'estime que
dans l'école de la République dans
l'école de la République on n pas à
comment dire pratiquer sa religion quel
que soit sa religion on pas pr dans des
cours cours des cours à part Ren tu
pries pas pries la
bibleig
PR dans
éle ce sont deux choses différentes le
même sujet même si ce sont deux choses
différentes je suis tout à fait d'accord
pour autant dire que ces enfants sont
fichés radicalisés mais cela charie le
même sujet si je puis dire c'est la
montée du fondamentalisme c'est la
montée du communautarisme islamiste donc
parler des radicalisés à l'école des
fichers c'est très bien mais en réalité
ça pose une question politique en amont
qui est la question de la montée de
l'islamisme et aussi de la question
migratoire parce que ces sujetsl ils se
posent pas dans les monde du Cantal si
vous voulez ces questions de
radicalisation il se POS essentiellement
en banlieu dans un endroit on a mal à
simuler on a mal inér comend iseou par
ça passe où où est-ce que ça passe
est jus vous étiez cohérent mesur plus
là vousez complètement bientôt vous
allez nous dire que c'est à cause des
musulans non c'est l'origine oui c'est à
cause des chrétiens aussi sans dout ah
vous dites
VO Islam il y a un petit lien je suis
pas en train de dire que T
les je ne suis pas en train de dire que
tous les sont Thor je suis en train de
vous dire que si nous n'ouvrons pas les
yeux sur origine du problème qui est que
vous le vouliez ou non et vous avez
plaidé pour le livre ensemble pend des
années je vous ai suivi aussi à la
télévision si nous ne revoyons pas notre
politique migratoire nous allons
constater la montée de ce phénomène
année après vous savez d'où elles
viennent ces deux familles vous n'avez
vous ne savez savez d'O elles viennent
elles habit sont leur orig non mais vous
ne savez même pas moi je sais pas ça pas
été dit mais quoi arrête mais vous saz
pas impossible de dire ça elles viennent
d'où savez pas moi non plus donc je
m'avance pas même les parents ont dit
SAV pas pourquoi les enfants
d'ù vient le communautarisme islamiste
est-ce que c'est une question qui se
posait en France il y a 80 ans est-ce
que c'est une question qui s'est posée
en France les siècles passés non c'est
un phénomène nouveau et ce phénomène
nouveau est lié à la politique
migratoire voilà que vous vouliez ou non
c'est le sujet de base c'est le sujet
d'origine si nous n'avions pas la
politique migratoire telle qu'elle est
regardez les pays de l'Est il NT pas du
tout ce problème est-ce qu'on a un
problème de communaut islamiste en
Pologne non on n pas ça on n pas ça en
Hongrie non plus parce que la politique
migratoire n'est pas la même il a des
liens monur de cause à effet c'est tout
et il y a un autre problème parce que
voyez vous vous ramenez ça très
strictement à la question de l'islamisme
et éventuellement de l'islam c'est que
en utilisant un terme tel que radicalisé
en réalité on ouvre une porte qui est
celle qu'on a déjà ouverte avec la
question du séparatisme qui est de dire
que dans les fichiers s il y a pas que
les fichiers S pour radicalisation
islamique il y a aussi les gens pour
radicalisation écologique ou pour
d'autres sujets et donc en fait on ouvre
une porte qui est de dire demain si vous
avez un gamin 15 ans qui est passionné
de la question écologique et qui
organise devant son lycée une petite
manifestation avec ses copains bah on
fait quoi on les sort on les met dans
des centre de déradicalisation de
l'écologie donc en fait c'est aussi que
on ouvre une boîte de Pandor qui est
très très risquée parce que au lieu de
se dire c'est des gamins et donc on les
prend tels qu'ils sont et on essaie de
les ramener dans le droitchemin mais au
sein même du cercle scolaire habituel on
est en train de dire on va créer des
sortes d'enclaves dans lesquelles on va
mettre des gens qu'on estime dangereux
puis une fois qu'on les sort bah ils
reviennent plus jamais je suis d'accord
avec
vousb c'est un peu facile de prendre
l'exemple des radicalisés écolo parce
que vous savez très bien ce qui passe
avec question on parle de deux choses
qui sont très différentes on a commencé
par évoquer les 1000 recensés fichers s
incl pour cela c'est de cela dont parle
c'est de cela dont parle Gabriel Atal
ensuite vous on était sur la question
des prières dans des écoles publiques et
dans des écoles laïques là il y a un
certain nombre de signalement depuis un
certain nbre d' années il y a des
rapports qui existent la réalité c'est
que c'est un phénomène qui s'accroit de
plus en plus question c'est pas la
pratique d'une religion la question
c'est le danger
est c'est pour ça que je dis qu'il ne
faut pas faire la confusion entre les
deux Dani Daniel je voudrais tavir ben
voilà moi je suis comme 86 % des gens je
vois un peu plus loin que simplement
deux enfants qui prient moi ça si on dit
simplement deux enfants qui pri c'est
formidable c'est génial sauf que on tout
tous les jours il y avait les aéroports
c'était des adultes ça gagne ça gagne et
voilà et et les gens sont inquiets parce
que la laïcité on on est en train de la
perdre
et C bafouer la laïcité la prière on est
d'accord excuse-moi je oui oui bien sûr
s'il y avait je serais aussi choqué on
l'a déjà dit je serais aussi choqué si
tout d'un coup dans une salle 10
personnes commen à dire la B même je
suis pas choqué par un enfant qui prie
mais ça gagne donc ça
gagne non on B fou la laïcité excuse-moi
dans un aéroport 15 personnes qui prient
dans la salle d'attente alors qu'il y a
100 m une salle pour ça je pense que
c'est c'est voilà c'est des testes c'est
des CH Oui excuse-moi si on me montrait
10 personnes 10 enfants par exemple dans
une salle qui dans une salle de classe
lambda qui tout d'un coup se metent à
lire la Bible ce serait aussi choquant
bien sûr puisque la laïcité elle est
elle est pour tout le monde je suis
désolé bien sûr mais ça mais on en a
moins le cas excuse-moi 8 pas faut pas
faut arrêter un peu de se voiler la face
merci en tout cas merci d'avoir été a
merci et merci Philippe h merci à vous
de d'avoir ét avec nous on va se
retrouver dans un instant avec le Z du
PO